always remember never accept the world
as it appears to be dare to see it for
what it could be
[Music]
[Music]
like that so that matter shows you where
everybody's logging in all over the
world select four o'clock when the
service goes live live live
Oh hopefully you'll start to see the map
lighting up this is now my doing
it's a 3:30 yes good and ready Oh
where's readies we're gonna be the
buttons being hit now go friend
all right we're up in all regions
[Applause]
people walking in right-hander the
floodgates have opened thank you so good
[Applause]
what is up everyone this is Jeff from
the overwatch team we were working on a
lot of things to update the game and
keep it fresh the word believed that I
was dead
but first a people will need to be
protected
reporting for duty
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
there's some candy
Pizza
welcome to Blizzcon 2016
I'm authorized person detective we are
delivering the payroll the overwatch
league represents next generation
eSports experience
please get up for the first ever
overwatch World Cup gold medalist South
Korea
[Music]
[Music]
how long is just gonna last it honestly
just depends if they're tackling the
objective or just messing around and
shooting each other in the face looking
forward to the new year there's a lot of
stuff coming
[Music]
the most impressive display ever Manny
Pacquiao
everyone else gave up on you but I saw
what you could be
what he saw online see notice
Larissa pushes the boundaries of what
the overwatch universe could be
come on
hey guys I'm here with Sombra on behalf
of all of us here at Blizzard we want to
thank you for what an awesome year this
has been for the overwatch community
thank you for everything you guys have
done
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah what awesome